janet yellen is worth only a fraction of
her predecessor's wealth
but among biden's cabinet the treasury
secretary's estimated 20 million dollars
is still downright rich yellen graduated
with a bachelor's in economics from
brown university in 1967
before heading to yale for her doctorate
degree
there she studied under left-leaning
economist james tobin
a former economic advisor in the kennedy
administration
whose career path bears remarkable
resemblance to yellens
after her own teaching stint at harvard
yellen eventually joined the federal
reserve
as an economist in 1976.
there in the fed cafeteria she met her
husband george ackerloff
a few years later the two moved to
california to teach economics and study
wages at uc berkeley
ackerloff eventually teamed up with two
economists to win the nobel prize in
2001.
meanwhile yellen returned to washington
to serve as chair of the council of
economic advisors
the same group her yale professor served
on some 30 years prior
after serving as chair yellen returned
to northern california
becoming president of the san francisco
federal reserve
in 2004. in that position
she issued early warnings on indicators
of a housing bubble
then in 2010 yellen crossed the country
yet again to serve as vice chair of the
federal reserve
four years later she was promoted to
chair a role she had hoped to serve in
for multiple terms
unfortunately for yellen trump replaced
her with jerome powell
in 2018 but the setback also provided
her with lucrative financial
opportunities
the same month she was replaced yellen
signed on with the washington speakers
bureau
in 2019 yellen took in about five
million dollars from speaking
according to a financial disclosure
report she submitted to federal ethics
officials
the next year she took in another 2.2
million dollars or so
mostly from big financial firms with an
interest in the federal reserve
and treasury by the end of 2020
yellen and her husband owned a diverse
portfolio of assets worth about 20
million dollars
roughly 4.3 million of it can be
attributed to real estate
2.2 million dollars for their home in
berkeley and 2.1 million dollars for
their home in dc
the couple also has millions of dollars
invested in an index fund
that tracks the s p 500 and millions
more in bond funds
at least 1.1 million dollars of their
fortune can be found in plain old cash
accounts
and most unusually yellen has a stamp
collection worth more than fifteen
thousand dollars
you